good evening thank you very much
um and welcome members to the central
area planning committee uh meeting of
modern District Council on Wednesday the
19th of April
2023. I'm councilor Carly Mays and I'm
the chairman of this committee
this meeting will be streamed live and
recorded and by being present in the
meeting you are giving consent to being
recorded members and officers during
each item please indicate if you wish to
speak I will then invite you to at the
appropriate time
I encourage all members to keep
contributions clear and concise when
invited to speak please remain seated
and speak clearly remembering to turn on
your microphone and then turn it off
when you finished
when referring uh wait sorry when
speaking and referring to agenda papers
please ensure you reference a page or
paragraph number
tonight we have offices
um Lisa Greenwood who is remote and Mr
Michael Johnson lead specialist
development Management Service delivery
uh Anna Clark is Sean good evening
officers
item two apologies for absence Sean can
you tell me um who we've had apologies
from please
apologies from councilors Edwards
thank you chair thank you
we moved to item three minutes of the
previous meeting and it is recommended
that these minutes of the central area
planning committee held on the 25th of
January 2023 are approved as a true and
accurate record they are presented for
accuracy only ISO move do I have a
secondar
thank you councilor Hurd are there any
matters of any accuracy that need to be
recorded
lovely can these be agreed by a cent
please
lovely thank you very much
interest sorry Declarations of Interest
members are reminded that they are
required to disclose the existence and
nature of any disclosable pecuniary
interests other registerable interests
and non-registerable interests relating
to items of business on the agenda
having regard to paragraph nine and
appendix B of the code of conduct for
members members are also reminded that
they are all required to disclose any
such interest as soon as they become
aware of it should the needs a need to
rise through the meeting
I firstly would like to declare um a
non-registerable interest in that I know
the um objectors and I know the
applicant
thank you
do I have any other declarations
councilor Shaughnessy
uh thank you chair yes
um I also know some of the um people
seated in the chamber thank you thank
you
councilor heard and thank you Jim I'm
also acquainted with one of the
objectives thank you
councilor Beale
yes chair I know some of the objectives
thank you
councilor spensely
I'm acquainted with both the applicant
and the objectors thank you any others
lovely thank you very much uh did you
get all of those Sean
yes thank you lovely thank you
uh we now move to item five application
at 22
01241 full Joshua 4 Silver Street Malden
on pages 11 to 23 in your packs The
Proposal is a change of use from C Class
C 3 dwelling house to sue generous
short-term holiday let
the applicant is Mr n bresler the agent
is Mr Simon platter
this application has become come before
us as it's been called in by councilor
Swain for reasons relating to policy D3
protection of a Heritage asset and
policy E5 specifically issues of on-site
parking provision lack of amenity space
and impact on neighboring properties
members have all had a copy of the
presentation that was circulated
yesterday Monday the 17th of April no it
wasn't the day before
sorry about that
um Miss Greenwood is going to present
the application Miss Greenwood
the application site is located on the
Eastern side of Silver Street which is
access north from The High Street the
sign which has been in the town center
and the Border Conservation Area
number four silver street is a grade two
listed building
and is labored by a number of Heritage
assets including the Bell the White
Horse and Chef's house at the rear
the 20 was first listed in 1971.
research has shown that parts of the
dwelling day back to 1400 however the
building has been altered over the years
and now has 20th century editions
including a two-story range to the rear
planning permission analysty Building
Concept were also recently granted for
the restoration and alterations to the
exterior and interior of the existing
house
these applications work once before
consent by the planet committee and
these works are underway
Planning Commission is now sought for
the change of use for a residential
dwelling to a short-term holiday lens
there are no internal or external
alteration source
with regards to principle of development
as stated the site is within the Town
Center
the local plan is clear that the Central
Area will continue to act as a focal
point within the district for retail
commercial industrial community and
tourism activities
policy eb-5 of the plan states that the
council will support developments which
contribute positively to the growth of
local tourism in a sustainable manner
the application has been supported by
Design and access statement which
provides information with regards to
sites
education and good connections to
tourist destinations and the green
infrastructure Network and sustainable
modes of transport
with regard to the need of such use the
report has also been submitted by newly
lettings this shows that there are less
than a hundred rental properties listed
in the district in comparison to
neighboring authorities such as
tendering which has almost 500 and
Braintree which has 250.
comments have also been received from
the strategy strategy team who
acknowledge the poor high quality
visitor and holiday accommodation is
needed in the district
and that the use of this building should
be specifically for holiday or
short-term elections to ensure it
supports the visitor offer and economy
consider an oceanography giving to the
conservation of the Heritage asset and
this application has been viewed by the
council's conservation officer who
raises no objection
foreign
as the proposal provides three tons of
car parking spaces and will require some
degree of loading and loading during
arrival and departure times the proposal
has been reviewed by the highway
Authority who raised their objection
it should also be noted that the site is
within a controlled parking area and
parking at Silver Street is restricted
to
assist and the parking Arrangement has
previously been accepted at the site
to residential dwelling although however
this is for a holiday event
concern has also been raised with regard
to the level of noise experienced at the
site 's result of the change at use
proposal has been reviewed by the
council's environmental health officer
who noticed that the proposed use could
have the potential for noise disturbance
as such should Planning Commission b4's
coming a condition is recommended to be
imposed with regard to the management of
noise generating activities
the applicant would be required to
produce produce a noise management plan
to ensure that reasonable measures are
put into place to reduce the impact of
noise
in addition conditions are to be opposed
to ensure the property reveals as a
short-term holiday let
managing the duration of occupancy of
single or groups of persons and for a
log to be maintained of all visitors
staying at the site
comments have also been received as to
whether the building can sustain 10
people
just pop back to the floor plans
it should be noted that the proposal six
to five for five double bedrooms across
the ground and first floor with
Associated communal areas whilst the
patents are coming to going to main
difference of single household this is
not uncommon for a site situated but
situated within a town center location
particularly whereby neighboring uses
include a guest house and a hotel
the private immunity set space provided
also remains unaltered
to conclude the proposal does not
include any Intel or external
alterations whilst it is acknowledge
that a number of objections have been
received no technical objections have
been received
the site is located within the Town
Center
there is there are no planning
objections to the principle of the
proposed use subject to the imposition
of suitably worded conditions to ensure
the use remains to short-term let and
further information is attained with
regards and waste management before the
commencement of such change the proposal
has been found to satisfy
policy S1 S5 and E5 of the local
development plan and will represent the
sustain
Ed development it is therefore
recommended that Planning Commission is
granted
so
thank you
um Miss Greenwood I would just like to
point out that this application relates
to a grade to style listed building
um I have had that just checked by Mr
Johnson so I'd like members to actually
note that it is a grade two listed grade
two star listed property not a grade two
thank you
um councilor Swain yes
uh yes could we
um
clear lights now
yeah press them and then there was light
fabulous thank you
thank you
thank you very much
um we have one public participant for
this application an objector Mrs Suzanne
wood
uh Sean could you put the clock up for
me please
um Mrs wood could you come forward
thank you
thanks Kevin
that's okay
lovely thank you
um
can you turn the microphone on for me
thanks thanks Kevin
um Mrs wood in line with the public
participation scheme and I invite you to
read your submission
um please take a seat and turn
microphone on we've done that thank you
very much
um I have to remind you that you're
allocated two minutes for public
speaking and your two-minute start when
you first start to speak
okay
I'm speaking on behalf of many local
residents to object to the current
proposal based on the negative impact to
the neighborhood in a mainly residential
street in the heart of the Conservation
Area
prior to any planning permission this
site was advertised as a venue for large
parties with dining for 16 people in a
disco facility in the cellar for over 30
people no official disclosure of this
was made in 2021 application even though
the applicant stated in the first Town
Council planning meeting his intentions
this fact was deemed ultravirus to the
application but is raised here because
we have a clear demonstration of the
scale of the intended use
despite supporting the last application
without visiting the site English
Heritage refuses to comment on this one
environmental health raises concerns
about this detrimental impact suggesting
a noise management plan of restrictions
on group type before development but
this is not possible due to the
um the mockery the applicant has made of
the planning process we are two years
down the line with a property already
over developed Beyond its current remit
as a residential dwelling
now with five double bedrooms with
ensuite we could expect parties of 10
adults arriving in five cars in a
residential dwelling suitable for up to
six people
they're already guest options in Silver
street with supervised accommodation
the government and many local councils
are clamping down on these short-term
lets due to the negative impact suffered
by local residents
over capacity leads is to highlight only
two parking spaces according to the 2021
application this is completely
inadequate to cope with this level of
occupancy and will cause significant
disturbance locally therefore we request
this building remain a dwelling
for up to six people
thank you
do you want to take your yeah see thank
you very much Mr wood
before we move
um and I open the debate
um I think I would like to say that I
was very disappointed that there was no
comment
um from Heritage England and they very
much took a a back seat and decided not
to
um become embroiled or whatever I think
that was unhelpful uh given the
importance of this building
members are now open the debate and
invite you to put any questions or make
any comments you have on the report
I think I'd like to go to councilor
Swain first as
um he called it in
um even though it's my award
councilor Swain
yes thank you mnm chairman
um yes this is an unusual property and I
mean it's developed from a presidential
commercial thing into a rather large
residential property and perhaps if the
Town and Country planning act has been
exist we'd be looking at a cou paa from
commercial change at the back but as it
is changing the whole thing to
letting and parody short-term letting
um creates totally different proposition
and a number of the things that a number
of the points that officers have made in
supporting the application seemed to me
a little bit wider than Mark given this
change of use
proposal they may seem to relate to a a
four to five bed property
um in single residents and
um there are a whole number of areas the
parking
um the
um as a single use immunity space
the amount of waste likely to be
generated
the egress into Silver Street
the impact on the locality of neighbors
and the lack of four by four
so five beds for an inch which has been
mentioned by the one of the agents now
this may already all apply if it was
looked at as a single residence and I
think looked at as um
a short-term holiday let with five
bedrooms we are all those considerations
really go out of the window
because
um
the parking would inevitably involve
more Vehicles which would reduce the
amenity space below what it should be
there would be more waste generated than
um otherwise
there would be a lot of vehicle movement
to maneuvering out into Silver Street if
somebody wanted to get out from the far
end of the the um well the parking lot
um and uh the
nature of the use
um would impact on the locality uh the
officers are put in conditions about
um uh logging the occupancy and a noise
management
plan and
um
uh I I find it difficult to see how they
will actually operate and be enforceable
or be enforced and I think that it's
almost impracticable some of these
control or conditions that um are being
mentioned
lastly on the
um
accommodation fund from a tourism point
of view well I don't think we're talking
about tourists we're talking about
partisan group parties coming into
Malden
um not not as tourists but
as parties in Malden
um not to tour
um
and as far as parking concerns I think
it's unrealistic to suppose that
anybody's going to go out and park in
White Horse Lane when they are
accommodated in Silver street
um and we have to bear in mind there was
a Travel Lodge just down the bottom of
the hill
so uh all told I think a lot of the
boxes that the officers have ticked
don't really
stand up if that's a bad mythical thank
you thank you
councilor Hurd
um thank you chairman uh I I take a
different view to to council the Swain
and it has been highlighted by the
officer actually this application is not
talking about any internal or external
alterations it's merely change of use
and that's really what we need to decide
upon whether the change of use is
acceptable or not there's no technical
reason to refuse this in my view
I think this will extend the offer for
tourism uh I hold a great story in what
is said by the conservation officer and
he has no objections indeed I I know
that he's been working alongside uh the
applicant in relation to this
um
could I just ask the officer it does say
in the report three parking spaces are
available
but we've heard that there are only two
could we just confirm that Mr Johnson
through you chair yes of course um Miss
Greenwood
hello and as part of the disability
consent and the householder application
which is the works that are going on at
the moment the plans showed two parking
spaces and in the officers report
um it was mentioned that through 20 of
this size if we're looking at it as a
dwelling which will work at Backstage
normally we would look at three parking
spaces however because of the Town
Center location and the existing use the
two spaces were accepted
the plans for the change of use show
three parking spaces because they show
two at the back and one under the car
port now if you look at our parking
standards
um I think it was decided that obviously
we've taken a position that two would be
acceptable and
is being assessed as a holiday let as
opposed to a residential dwelling and I
went to the sites house center location
um that we would accept to
uh yeah Miss Greenwood can you can you
just clarify whether the um car parking
spaces would meet any of our criteria or
only the mppf criteria
I believe they may be slightly short but
marginally on length thank you thank you
yes uh so uh so so my my point is that
because it because this is a uh a
Central Central location it it is
possible uh that this may be a drop-off
point for example we don't know but they
might say just uh parking to drop off
and then and then Park if anyone who's
had uh um city breaks or uh even
somewhere in a town you can't always
park right outside the venue
um I think it's it's good that there is
a noise generation condition
um but I think when when I'm looking at
the reason that we're here tonight
looking at the change of use
um I would be inclined to support the
officer's recommendation I understand
that there have been objections but I
can't see a technical reason why we
should say no
thank you councilworheard any other
comments counselor Lagan yeah thanks
very much indeed share
um
unusually I agree with the councilor
herd unfortunately
um Silver Street obviously being born in
the town I've known all my life and it's
a beautiful Street and the bell house
was renovated
um by the fries years ago it's a it's a
marvelous asset
um and it's it's complicated but as
Council heard says you're only here to
look at what's in front of you based on
the technical information provided by
professional officers
and it looks like it's policy compliant
um and there's no technical objections
so it would we could be deemed as being
unreasonable if we if we just voted It
Out On Emotion
um councilor Swain is racing
um points but those points are very
subjective
um because you don't know
um and not everybody goes along to have
a rave up and a party
um I myself go to many different areas
with family and are highly respectful
um and especially in a building with
this is not
um
a substandard building when it's
finished I mean I'm sure it's going to
be a premium offering for the market and
tourism well if you go to a town you're
a tourist so you know one of the
objectives in the the ldps is to promote
tourism and an offering like this
um emotionally I'm going to admit very
very very split but from a perspective
of what we're here to ascertain
um again like counselor herd and
slightly regrettably I'd have to go and
support the recommendation of the
officers
thank you
counselors uh Spencer
um so trying to look at this very
logically with what's what's before us
here one of the things that does concern
me is that a noise management plan is
something that's recommended as a
condition but that we don't have sight
of it now and being that this is a
change of use application I would really
have liked to have seen that as part of
this because my concern is is when
that's put in place that as members we
won't get to look at what that involves
so
that that's a concern because if we're
going to take the responsibility of
passing this I would like that to be
part of the application I can see Mr
Johnson's already getting ready to to
respond I was just going to but so I I
will I would just listen to the response
thank you uh Mr Johnson
thank you thank you chairman
um I mean this sort of use isn't one
that
would automatically be considered as a
significant noise generating operation
um it's a use in a residential dwelling
it's the existing dwelling it's not been
extended
um the occupancy is not one that could
not be unreasonable for a very large
family and obviously if you have a very
large family yeah
um it's while there are a couple of
parking spaces
um there are no opportunities for one
street parking spaces there are
significant parking restrictions in the
area
um so even if you thought about a number
of individuals uh occupying these rooms
um
you know there wouldn't be car parking
spaces to accommodate and they couldn't
park on the street other than loading
and unloading they would have to find
parking elsewhere the Town Center is one
which attracts
um
tourists who wouldn't principally be
looking to drive or if they are looking
to drive they'd be parked in a public
parking space I mean specifically within
the report
um
at
I just find the relevance section
um
yeah it's a bit about the parking
maybe Lisa can find it uh quicker than I
can
um yeah
5.4.6
I just wanted to draw out where parking
issues have been considered on appeal
um at 119 High Street Malden but there
have been some other appeals where
inspectors have taken a general line
about particular developments within the
town center and car parking
um I mean just for the benefit of others
in the in the in the space here
um inspector talks about
two nearby public car parks
um
um and in this one the council does not
refuted the fact that residents could
have overnight stroke parking permits
annual parking permits for these car
Parks there's been no technical Highway
objection as also in the case here so
for all those reasons there would be no
unacceptable impact on highway safety
and and the residual cumulative impacts
on the road Network would not be severe
and also in this case there's been no
technical objections no highway safety
issues have have been raised so in terms
of that in terms of the sort of like the
noise mitigation there is one that that
policy does material considerations
around that
it's there's no I mean I do I do
appreciate the concerns raised with the
with the objector on the previous use
I'm well aware of that
um I was involved in in that application
um um any such use in that building
would have been completely unacceptable
but that's not what was approved at that
time yeah
um the people may have intentions but it
means nothing unless it's something
that's material to what's in front of us
there is nothing in that sense material
to us we can't base our decisions on
what we think might happen we can only
base it on what's in front of us and
what's in front of us is a
um
tourist related activity similar to
others in the area
um
in new demand has been raised as they
set out in the report by the Specialists
who are looking into these in these
particular matters
the noise and activity mitigation is
something that I thought about has been
useful to have just so that there's a
measure of control
um it's not something we would normally
seek up front it's not for example a
validation matter for these sorts of
applications but it's one in which there
will be a commitment
um from the from the applicant
um
these matters would be enforceable
um for example if there was untoward
activity that was contrary to what's in
the plan the residents can complain it's
something we can pick up from it from
enforcement
um that's most similar also to the waste
in terms of how waste would be managed
we you know there's a conditional in a
waste management plan that again it's
not something we would normally seek up
front for development of this type but I
thought it would be useful so that way
it can be management and they can adhere
to that and these are enforceable
thank you chairman uh thank you Mr
Johnson did you want to come back
um my um I'm still concerned regarding
the noise and activity management plan
and the fact that I'll come to you in
just a moment
um Council bill
um and the fact that we don't have sight
of that particularly given that this
site is a very sensitive site and it is
a sensitive building there is a lot of
as you can see
um
concern as to its future use
um and I think that management plan
would have been useful in helping us to
decide what we were going to do going
forward
what sort of thing would be included in
that sort of management noise and
activity management plan
that would allay members fears um that
it you know it wouldn't become well yeah
and I'm an unruly uh House of Activity
thank you chairman I mean the first
thing I'd have to say we can't take a
position that this use will be unruly I
mean that that sounds particularly
prejudicial to uh uh occu you know to
the type of occupiers the type of
occupiers being Taurus I mean
councilorgan made a reference to even
himself as a tourist
um and I think that that that's
something that most of us have have done
uh in our lives in visiting other places
we don't go there with an intention of
being unruly
um this is not a a building which has a
dedicated space and I think it was also
mentioned by the officer you know there
is no restaurant type facilities to be
taken place within this building is
purely for uh bed sitting there is a
reception rooms where they can watch TV
these are not party spaces but I suppose
any noise management plan would just
confirm term
and it's not a requirement it's not
something that for example we could
refuse an application out outright if
that's not submitted
any such decision on that basis would be
completely unreasonable and probably
cost awarded for unreasonable behavior
um so this is merely a built-in braces
um you know it's something that we would
normally consider with our environmental
health officers
um they would they would uh consider it
from a technical point of view
as much as one can do for that type of
management but I mean management and
being respectful and reasonable in
occupancy of any sort of accommodation
like this is something that's part and
parcel of these operations in most
places you know there are other sort of
terms and conditions when you you know
when you go to these places to rent a
space You Can't Behave how you you want
to There are rules and regulations the
management plan is purely to just sort
of capture that and to ensure that
similarly also for us to ensure the type
of occupancy and again we need to be
careful about who we think these groups
of people might be but it's again just
to make sure that
if there were any intentions otherwise
that the premises may be used for
occupancy other than short-term let's
for tourism purposes you know the
address and the details of of of any
occupiers must be given
um a register must be kept and must be
available for us to inspect at any time
as we see fit
thank you thank you chairman thank you
uh councilor Beale
how long have I got
how long you would like good I've got a
big list here excellent uh not happy
about this at all this this is another
special where this guy
makes out is actually giving you what
you want but he's not
I mean can you imagine going there as I
mean right let's start in the list
currently in use as a dwelling no it's
not
it's a building site
um is it managed the noise management I
know they've got that but this isn't a
short-term let this is a hotel
we've got more than enough spaces with
the Premier Inn I think it is down the
causeway you've got the blue ball
there's another one down um once Road
but it's not a short-term let and how
long is a short term let
um is it going to be a family is it
going to be five different couples no
council Bill if I if I could draw your
attention to the conditions
um holiday accommodation not more than
28 days
and no reoccupation within three months
by the same person
um so it is short term 28 days is deemed
to be short-term no one's going to
accomplish 28 days are they
um can you imagine I mean you got
highways saying they've got no objection
they're saying they've got three car
parking spaces I don't know many hotels
that have cars parked one behind the
other
you know and and the residents got a
valid point if you've got someone at the
back of that them three cars who wants
to get out you then gotta get hold of
the other two people to get them to move
their car for you to get out it's not a
practical solution
and why haven't the highways kicked up
there's double yellow lines both sides
of that road
it tells you how narrow the road is
um where are we is the seller still
going to be used for music and
socializing I can clarify that point and
I think the officer can also clarify
that no the seller has been blocked up
and is not accessible at all
and he says it's not going to be in any
increase in um Refuge or recycling
unknown or there might not be skips here
but there's going to be bins
it's not it's not lifting at the minute
this is basically retrospective
the amount of work they're doing on that
building what are they building
are they building it as a family home
have they started building it as a
family home internally are they building
it as a Holiday Lab
it's retrospect they've gone ahead with
all this work
before they even put the application in
okay I'd like um Miss Johnson to come
back on that thank you Mr Johnson thank
you
um chair
um the
this is a grade two style listed
building
um it's not building you can go in and
just hack up and turn around within a
few weeks there is careful restoration
which needs to be adhered to otherwise
it would be a criminal offense to to
hack up the building we can't make
suppositions unless we have a valid
basis on which to say that
um and unless there is valid basis
that's something that can be taken up
through other mediums particularly if
it's a listed building that's a straight
prosecutable matter
the plans of clearly what's in the
building is within the application
um
it would be unreasonable for us to be
making assumptions about
the layout or what works have been done
to the building without making reference
to the plans and the plans have been
shown
um Miss Mrs Greenwood has the plans
um on the screen they're available for
the public to see on on the website so
clearly what the building is and these
are restoration works
um not for the
um applicant to do what they want
um and that's quite clear so I I would
just exercise caution in terms of how
um we may think that the building uh
would be without clearly knowing what
the building is and what's proposed so
it's not going to be specifically five
couples it could be a couple with two
four children whatever so they take
three bedrooms that that's not for us to
control
um you you have double bedrooms I'm
trying to justify the way they're asking
people to park
and the inconvenience and then if there
isn't space
if say for example you've got five
couples that's potentially five cars
what do you expect the other people to
do go and park in our
will you keep on about the Town Center
car parks how much is it a day
on top of the letter in the let
that is not something that we can
actually control
no but what I'm saying is they're saying
there's only two to three car parking
spaces but if there are five families in
there where are they gonna Park
you know it's just as I said he's making
out that he's giving you everything that
you want they're saying there's no
objections to this satinum it's agreeing
with this policy in that policy but it's
not
what other questions do you have
I got any more I'll mentioned highways
is there going to be any Management on
site
it's basically short term let without
management on-site management there will
be no there will be it will be off-site
management there is
yeah there has to be to put in bookings
that's how Airbnb works
yeah other other short-term lets are
available
um
uh Miss Greenwood
thank you to make a point with regards
to the work that are going on these are
works that were agreed at the planning
committee and by the county committee
and I know Tim house and the
conservation officer is working really
really closely with the developer to
make sure that these works are in
accordance with the clouds and as
Michael said I appreciate it it may look
as if they're ongoing but that's been
asked me to be
a certain quality for the ability The
Works that are going on are in
accordance with the plans
thank you Miss Greenwood
councilor um actually can I go to
Council of uh Shaughnessy again and then
I'll go to councilor um Swain
yes thank you chair
um you you mentioned a little while ago
yourself about the blocking off of the
sellers yes
um now I I remember
um on the first application here about
the metal doorways um etc for blocking
off the sellers and and I and I'm pretty
sure that we didn't allow that because
sellers need to breathe can Mr Johnson
or Ms Greenwood um please reassure me
that that metal is not going anywhere
near the sellers that it will be like
for instance wood or whatever to block
the sellers off do you know how they've
been thank you
uh Miss Greenwood do you know how the
sellers have been sealed
could we
could beat you
I just said I mean that's not part of
this application
um however however
um all I will say is although it may not
be part of this application it is
directly
um uh
um
uh relevant because it it accesses a
space that we did not give planning
permission for
would be able to
this this application just applies to
the ground and the first floor it
doesn't apply to the seller so the
seller isn't isn't part of this so you
wouldn't have people being able to come
in and go into the seller separately
because they wouldn't have access to
customer you you can gain
changes
professionally
so what has
transportation of certainly what remains
we're not making any changes whatsoever
to that building
I seem to remember that there was
something about blocking up the service
I've read somewhere that there was
Mr Johnson no I just wanted to confirm
that the application concerns the ground
on the first floor it does not relate to
the seller there is no proposals with
with this seller to pursue a line of
consideration about the impact of or or
assumed impact of use of the seller
related to this application would be
quite dangerous thank you very much yeah
thank you
it does make up part of the building and
is accessible from the center of the
building
so there is a concern and I can
understand that concern especially as we
don't have an assurance that there is no
access to it
um
I'd like to go yeah come back to uh
my um question was purely because of
um you know looking after this building
in the correct way you know it is as
we've been told a grade two star listed
building
um and you know if things
um I I get what people say that you know
the application this evening is is what
it is but you know we do have to take
care of this building
um and particularly if it's going to be
used
um you know for these short term let's
if that's what's um going to happen this
evening
um and uh you know
the the care of the sellers is very much
um you know in my mind as care for this
building
thank you thank you thank you uh
councilor Swain
oh yes thank you chairs just want to
come back on the um what Mr Johnson said
about the noise and activity management
plan
um and what we're looking at with
short-term lets which but is more likely
to be weekly than
um and um any problems that arise
um
will not be enforceable that because the
people who had been gone before anybody
even gets around to looking at the issue
um
it would all be retrospective so from
that point of view is certain is is
there a question that um
this that this can be subject to
Licensing in some way
um so that the short term letting
provision could be suspended
yeah I mean in my in my experience there
are there are licenses implications this
is outside of the planning regime
um but this is not again something for
our consideration
that would it how that may apply to this
business has to be pursued separately
but it can't form part of our our
decision making
um
so how are these people eating
are the five couples or whatever
occupants in there is there a communal
kitchen or does the company Supply I
don't know bed and breakfast or whatever
um is there going to be a bar in there
could you um provide the plan please
can you make that just a little bit
bigger so we can see the dining area
because there was a dining area from
recollection
I can make it bigger unfortunately but
there is a there is a large dining area
if you could just see my cursor just
moving to
that room there there's a large dining
area there
is also a large kitchen to the rear here
[Music]
which is is more than sufficient
I think we would probably also hope that
they might use some of the facilities in
Malden as this is a tourist attraction
but but there is there is sufficient
catering in there and continual spaces
as well I think there are spaces
obviously on the ground floor but also
on the first floor as well there's a
sitting room here
that they can enjoy so that there is
space for eating okay does that answer
your question counselor bill
no
um so potentially you've got five
families using one kitchen
and it's it's a communal area this
dining area
as in the same sort of arrangement you'd
have in a hotel
no because they eat in their room it
wouldn't be five different families you
know it's uh
I'm not not sure that that's how it how
it works it's not like a guest house
um where you have different rooms
allocated to two people two people two
people two people
um and then there's someone on site to
do your breakfast or whatever it's it's
a it's a a building that would be used
by a family or it's like an extended
family
um for a holiday
so you're saying it's just for one
family at a time effectively yes that
well that's certainly my understanding
hold on
um councilor heard oh sorry I'm I'm very
sorry I
um Council lag on first and then Council
heard thank you I think we're getting
lost in the weeds here yeah you can't
you can't say who's going to eat how
they're going to read what they're going
to eat you can't say who's going to use
it you know there's there's all my
family going into Bristol tomorrow to
stay in a house okay there's eight of us
so there's the facilities there and
we're going to go and use the facilities
and respect facilities so I think we
we've been distracted a little bit about
the emotion of the whole thing because
it is a very emotive aspect but we can't
say that the the plan in legislation
that allows this report to be developed
to to discuss it there's a lot of things
about being reasonable and unreasonable
and the the you know this is why
planning is such a venomous subject in
in my view because some of the things
you want to do you basically can't do
because the mppf and the policies allow
these things to happen but you can look
at it and you can say but what the
rabbit rubbish is going to be
regenerated we don't know what vehicles
are going to be you know they're not
going to be five different people Rock
up like they were in a guest house
that's just not how these things work
there will be noise surveys and
litigations put on it there is a
possible if there's noise enforcement
there's the police in the environmental
health officers that do come out very
quickly and we've got very good team in
Malden so all of those things I think we
we're just getting lost in the weeds I
think we're going to look at what here
look at the change of use look at what
the policies say and make a judgment
decision based on what's in front of us
there because I'm some of the worst
people as well for going off looking at
the emotive side of it but what's in
front of us is right in front of us you
know and there's the all of those things
are just the materials
um councilor heard and then I'm going to
draw the matter to um a close and we'll
move on
well thank you Jim actually I'm just
going to really Echo what council dragon
has said we have to be very careful
we're here to judge for this application
uh I understand I understand about the
seller
um but that's not what this application
is for uh it's also it's not a hotel
it's an Airbnb and b b stands for bed
and breakfast and the likelihood is that
these people may or may not dine out in
Malden but but the point is there's some
eating facilities there that's why it's
an Airbnb and the reason that it's uh
that it's not a hotel is because it
should be more affordable it should be
more homely there should be more
amenities than a standard hotel room I
appreciate we've got the premiere in but
clearly this is going to be at a more
reasonable cost than that but I really
do urge all members to think very
carefully about this look at what we've
got in front of us we can't say who is
going to stay there or indeed how many
there are all we need to do is to look
at what we have in the report and from
what we see in the report I can't see
any technical reason why we should
refuse this
members
um I need a proposal
well I'm happy to make the proposal and
chairman and that we go with the office
as a recommendation do I have a seconder
thank you councilor Lagann
um all those in favor please show by
hands please
two those against
three and abstentions
one
that has fallen however
um that leaves us in a situation where
we need a counter
um proposal
um
no I I did not vote
I did not vote
um we need a counter proposal wouldn't
make any difference anyway
um we need a counter proposal
um
to put on the table
from somebody
with with valid reasons obviously
the efficient parking for the
location and its hold up on it okay okay
man
um an impact in terms of
um noise
okay
um and um
and well and wasted especially I
especially particularly with turkey
and an impact on the neighborhood
to try it out
uh yeah I mean what I'd say about noise
and waste um it that would be very
difficult because conditions are
proposed to be attached to this
application regarding those those very
matters there are no objections from the
highway Authority so the local planning
Authority would have to
then become the highway Authority
without the relevant jurisdiction of the
highway authority to comment on these
particular matters
um any Appeal on this basis will put us
in a very difficult position and clearly
would lead us
um in a situation where costs would be
awarded for unreasonable behavior
community space
um and
um
inevitable impact on
neighbors and their localities so I
think we're still going to have the same
problem well yeah yeah I mean
to my recollection there was there was
no real discussion around immunity space
I mean what's what's the impact of the
amenity space what standards are we
comparing this against for us to say
that it's deficient
given the type of use
um
Miss Greenwood
no I just wanted to reiterate about the
private immunity space
dwelling
size this is not being assessed as a
dwellings they exist as a holiday let
um it was found to have acceptable
immediate space now that hasn't changed
um so therefore and also for the
short-term holiday you know there is no
requirement for it to be any gray term
therefore it has already been satisfied
on one hand and there is no need for it
to be satisfied on the other and
obviously with regards to the parking
and
as Mr Johnson said you know we have no
objection from from the highway
Authority and we have accepted the
parking position previously for a
household with five double bedrooms
which could accommodate just as many
people as as the short-term holiday and
actually require parking probably more
permanently
than that time of use where you may
arrange to travel with friends
use public transport to get to the
destination so
um I I think looking at it
surviving an appeal statement yes that's
fine yeah
um it would be quite challenging
appreciate the views but I feel it will
be quite challenging yeah thank you
um yeah just one other point I mean
reference in the report was made of of
an appeal decision not the appeal
decision in itself but a particular
element of the of the appeal decision
which is pertinent to this site in terms
of parking in the area and it has been
accepted by
um in inspectors
um not just on this appeal but there's
been a number of others I mean I've been
involved in refusing schemes on parking
and it's been shot down
um even in my time here
um the the the council as a whole has
been criticized also by the inspector
for not having regard to appeal
decisions as material considerations
that doesn't mean we can argue against
it but there are some generic things the
Town Center is is a generic thing
um developments within the Town Center
even if we look within our parking
standards there is a relaxation of
parking standards within Town centers
because there are policies of
restrainting in town centers
townsendizer areas where you you you
know you you have you know the greatest
access to public and alternative means
of Transport so that makes it very
difficult for us to argue against that
because that would be us arguing against
our own plan
thank you chairman uh uh thank you Miss
Johnson
um Miss Greenwood um
Mr Fairweather makes reference in his
[Music]
um
submission
um that we could look at additional
conditioning over an above noise and a
noise and activity management uh plan to
restrict the type of bookings that could
be taken
um is there any Merit in that that would
give members some solace
it's not something that I have seen
attached or I feel for you know as a
planner it would be my position to put
those kind of restrictions on a decision
notice I think that type of arrangement
would be dealt with by the letting
company
so that would be um by consent
okay thank you I just wanted to explore
every Avenue
um available at every Avenue available
um and I think
um I'd like to just go back to the
conditions so there's um there are six
conditions
um three years permitted development so
they've got to do they've got to start
the development within three years
um everything has to be done in line
with the plans it's holiday
accommodation not more than 28 days or
reoccupation by the same person or
people within
um three months
um there will be a register of occupants
and prior to to starting any sort of uh
occupation the noise and activity
management plan which I feel is actually
crucial to this to be fair and gives
members
um the uh reassurance going forward and
hold on a sec
um and um uh the waste management plan
uh which I would have expected to see
there um is there so there are no
advisories they are the six conditions
Mr Johnson
thank you thank you chairman um
when conditions are submitted it's not
to say that nobody can see them they
just may not come to commit it yeah yeah
that does not stop
um
members from inquiring about what the
details of the applications are in the
way that they may inquire about details
of of any applications
um
I mean I can I mean in speaking for
myself and and my offices I mean putting
on a condition like that is not
something we would look at lightly no as
you know in my remit as also
um managing the enforcement Services I'm
quite sure what's enforceable and what
isn't
um
I'm quite happy that any officer that
will be dealing with the discharge if
condition would be happy to discuss with
any members the details of of the
um of of the noise and management plan
submitted they can't start the
development until these are submitted
and cleared by us
um if they're not satisfactory we refuse
them it's as simple as that they can't
start the development they have
opportunities to come back or they can
appeal against the condition
is there any way to
um
ensure that that noise and activity
management plan is agreed with some
member input whether it's the chairman
of the
um the committee
um
I've not ever seen that some in all of
my almost 30-year experience in planning
showing my age
across quite a number of authorities I
have to say uh but it's not to say that
there can't be discussions clearly we
have had discussions we can discuss
details of conditions with any member as
we come with any application
um so they fully understand what what's
involved
um
any concerns raise our legitimate yeah
obviously it's just not a planning
application to follow the that planning
application route but not that they
can't be taken into considerations but
this is something we would just consider
I mean I've dealt with a number of these
applications so I'm I'm quite clear on
on in regression of the officer to
impose these conditions what I'd be
looking for in terms of management thank
you thank you
um councilor Beale then um I'm not sure
which one was first actually counselor
um heard and councilor Shaughnessy
councilor bail thank you chair I'm
actually going to agree with the
officers that probably the parking is a
weak link
um I don't think it's strong enough to
win an appeal but I think it's a totally
inappropriate use of that building it's
it's it's a residential area if it was
such a wonderful
development
and I think there's about two three
hundred years old if not older
then I'm sure someone would have come up
with that idea before
but I think it's an inappropriate use of
that building in the area
because of the
uh what's the way of putting it because
of the disruption and everything else to
the neighborhood
I don't know if that's illegal no you
know if you get no that's the point of
clarity but but I think it's just a
totally inappropriate use of that
building in a listed a solicited
building it's in a residential area
and it's totally out of character with
the area I'm gonna say to my
understanding that's not the only listed
building which is used for this purpose
in the area thank you chairman now the
one next door is used for it as well as
is the blue ball
um
uh councilor heard
well I I really am very very concerned
about this chairman um I think uh if um
we've we've taken a vote to follow the
officer's recommendation and that has
failed so obviously we we are looking to
come up with a reason to approve this
and I think to be honest we're
struggling and if in the event uh that
the refusal fails then I will be making
a further recommendation
thank you
um Council Shaughnessy
thank you chairman um I've listened very
carefully to what um
Mr Johnson has been saying and Ms
Greenwood
um I don't really think there is any way
out of this legitimately
um so I'm asking chairman if I would be
allowed to change my vote
um I think we have to go back to uh
bringing another proposal I need a
proposal on the table in order to
um take this forward
make it short is is there a current fire
plan because it's not like it's a family
home where you can just have smoke
detectors not a material consideration
[Music]
sorry thank you
councilor Hurd well I'm happy to make um
the recommendation once again uh that we
should go with the officer's
recommendation and and I hope that all
members will vote on this because I
think it is a very very important issue
and
I won't be jumping up and down with Glee
if this passes no no but the point is
we've got to look at the evidence in
front of us and we've got to listen to
the officers the conservation officer
the experience of Mr Johnson and I'm
really concerned that we will lead this
Council down to an irreversible Journey
thank you
um do I have a second
thank you councilor Lagoon
can I ask for a vote in favor to raise
hands please
this is to accept the officer's
recommendation
uh one two three four
and I will vote five
those against
one
and those abstaining
and one abstention the matter is uh
carried thank you
I understand that was a very difficult
decision
and not one that any of us like you said
has taken any joy in in
thank you um we will now move on please
could you remove yourself from the the
chamber thank you
thank you
I will now move to item six any other
business that is the chairman of the
committee decides is urgent I have none
members and officers thank you very much
for your time and your contributions
this evening
um and I now uh thank everybody that is
also watching streaming and I now draw
the meeting to a close at 8 34 pm